let's bring in our panel early former
education secretary bill bennett harold
ford jr former tennessee congressman ceo
of empowerment inclusion capital and
byron york chief political correspondent
of the washington examiner bill
for some it felt like this was a long
time and it dragged on but if you look
at
kind of how things evolved how do you
see this resignation today that comes 14
days from now
well it's over and i think the whole
country is grateful that it's over
republicans democrats everybody uh
listening to soliloquy today and then
last week i thought of those immortal
lines from the exorcist for god's sakes
get out
and it's time that he did and i'm glad
that he did now there may be these
trials i hope people can focus on what
seemed to me the most important
questions of law which is the liability
of andrew cuomo if criminal or civil for
these nursing homes the deaths of people
in these nursing homes let that not be
forgotten and let's carry forward on
that but i'm glad this chapter is over i
think there are a lot of lessons here
too and a major one for the media but i
don't want to occupy all the time yeah
to your point about the nursing homes
the lawmaker who was spearheading that
ron kim a democrat
weighed in on this resignation today
ticklist
i'm relieved that he stepped down so we
can focus on the people's work i'm also
grateful for the woman who stepped up
courageously but i have committed back
in march that after he goes down for
sexual assault and harassment i will
still be here to hold him accountable
for the thousands of nursing home debts
that that happened under his watch
byron in the big picture there were a
lot of people who said that that was so
much more egregious
you know not in the scale of of how
things are bad but as far as the impact
on families across new york
well what was clear is that the the
attorney general's report killed him
he just could not survive it any
democrat who might have been inclined to
support him
fell away after the attorney general's
report and the reason he resigned today
had nothing to do with the the whole
coveted nursing home thing it was
because
he saw that after the attorney general's
report he did not have the minimum level
of support necessary to stay in office
and today was very strategic his event
was very strategic it began with his
lawyer going on for nearly an hour
attacking that report
nearly line by line questioning the
credibility of all of the allegations
and then the governor himself came out
and again attacked the report
questioning its credibility and he
admitted to small things he said well
you know my sense of humor can offend
people sometimes and maybe i'm an old
fogey and i haven't realized how the
rules for interactions between men and
women in the workplace have changed but
he was clear to say that he did nothing
wrong and this is for really for a
couple of reasons he still might face
criminal charges he couldn't very well
come out today and admit it so he denied
everything in terms of any potential
charges against him and the other thing
is he's 63 years old
he thinks maybe in a few years things
could change conditions could change
something unexpected could happen and he
might be able to run for office again so
that's what this resignation today was
about which is truly amazing if you
think about the media coverage of this
governor
lifting him up in covid
the really vaunted status some people
wanted him to run for president then
they were naming him harold as a vice
presidential candidate today
immediately following the resignation
speech on another channel there was this
as byron just mentioned a cuomo comeback
we know the way our world works
it's amazing the people we've seen make
political comebacks
you know you can't ever rule it out he
eventually did
something that was that that maybe over
time
will at least give him an opening to
oh
maybe you know not be a full pariah in
the party say in in in three years four
years five years i expect
in my lifetime
andrew cuomo to probably run for office
again what that office is i don't know
but that's what this resignation tells
me today
can we wait like one hour maybe two
hours before the cuomo comeback analysis
harold
look first thanks for having me on i you
know that that's the kind of analysis
that comes and who knows i don't know
what will happen what the future holds
for him or or for any politician i do
know this though it was democrats
nationally and state and local new york
democrats that eventually brought an end
to
his governorship right now
they're going to be those who quarrel
with his resignation speech but at the
end of the day he resigned and it allows
the state to move forward it allows the
new governor lieutenant governor hochul
to take over and manage the recovery
manage to surge the covent 19th surgeon
tackle the crime and restore public
safety across the state but it's
important to note democrats held him to
the same standard that they've held
others around these issues
and at the end of the day it was the
president the speaker of the house in
washington the speaker of the state
assembly in new york
the senators and a whole host of
democrats that said enough was enough
all right here's just a review there
kind of a montage
to listen to take a listen
i never touched anyone inappropriately
the independence investigation found
that governor cuomo sexually harassed
multiple women some suffered through
unwanted touching and grabbing of their
most intimate body parts the governor
hugged executive assistant number one
and reached under her blouse to grab her
breast
i know the truth
he knows the truth
i know what happened and so does he the
best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back to governing
and therefore that's what i'll do
lieutenant governor kathy hokel bill
takes over in 14 days the governor's
mansion
um not clear her influence in albany or
how that will all transpire any thoughts
on the first female governor actually in
new york uh taking the reins
no i know very little about it but i
just want to say the point about the
media
because of the outsized presence of the
media in new york
we were saturated with this with this
coverage
and you know
many more important issues are going on
in this country the invasion of southern
border crime uh revolution in the
schools
brett i think you ought to suggest that
some of the major media may want to move
to florida
or some other state it would just would
be good in terms of you know
differentiating a little bit
we know it's an echo chamber when cbs
has lunch with nbc with the new york
times and i don't think the governor of
tennessee where harold's from or the
governor of north carolina where i'm
sitting if they had made these
pronouncements wouldn't have had near
the effect and this is partly because of
the incredible influence of new york
washington l.a disproportionate outside
harold any thoughts about the lieutenant
governor and her prospects and dealing
with albany which can be a tough place
to
make things happen
brad you talking to me yeah harold you
know new york i'm sorry you broke up one
second look i think look i think that
she will have her hands full
but she apparently has reaching out to
to some of the current aides that may
want to stay on she has her own team she
served in congress so she brings
relationships with members of congress
so as much as their hands will be full
because it's happening so quickly
i think she will i think she's going to
move into this position with with the
experience with the expertise and with
the relationships to do well the key
will be a good relationship with the new
new york city mayor which likely will be
eric adams okay panel we'll see at the
bottom of the show thank you very much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else